Hallelujah.
All right.
Did you
Make sure you kick it off
while she's doing the announcement.
Okay.
A slightly flat E major.
[Music]
So weird once you get your ears on like
you can't hear anything. I mean you get
it's so much harder to hear. I think
when you were talking to me earlier, I
was like, I almost like need you to lean
into the microphone so I can understand.
[Music]
There we go.
Can you noodle your way in from the
inter music?
I had
like
it was a slick move. Yeah. And we would
change the key of the video.
[Music]
Good evening. Welcome.
We're so glad you're here this evening.
[Music]
Hello. Hello. Test. Test.
Check. One, two. Check.
Okay. All right.
So, just speak into it. Okay. Thank you.
Welcome. Welcome. My name is Cat. My
pronouns are she, her, and we're so glad
that you're here this evening. If this
is the first time that you've walked
through doors in a while or every week,
we're so glad that you're here.
Um, we have a celebration of life for
our dear friend Will Humble. That will
be next week, next Saturday here in at
FUMC Saxi.
And that begins at 11. And all are
welcome.
We have a an accessibility bucket over
there for um if you have a little some
anxious uh anxiety about being here.
There's coloring sheets. There's fidget
spinners and fiddly things in there. Um
you're welcome to that.
Tonight is uh Hack Creek.
We will meet at Hack Creek after
service. all families. Hat Creek is
located on Highway 78. I forgot the
crossroad,
but um it's in Saxi.
So, we hope to see you at Hack Creek
this evening.
These candles are a sign of the presence
of Christ among us,
fully divine
and fully human.
[Music]
As we begin our time of worship,
I'd like to say that my heart is heavy
for the folks in
the Hill Country.
And I hope that you will lift them up as
we go into worship
and their families
at this time.
Now as we exit the kingdom of noise,
hurry and productivity.
Now we enter the kingdom of silence,
stillness,
grace.
Now we enter sacred space,
a space for prayer, worship, and
adoration.
of Spain to encounter Christ.
Revelation of God, heartbeat of
creation.
Allow the unforced rhythm of grace to
find you,
to mend your heart,
[Music]
to find love.
May we all come home.
[Music]
All right, if y'all would stand with us.
We're really glad to have you all here.
We know that it's been a very heavy news
week uh for for Texans and for the
world.
But one of the beautiful things we get
to do as a family, as a congregation, is
getting to sing together and getting to
praise God even in the hard times. It
does something for the soul. So if you
would like to sing with Yes.
[Music]
Sometimes on this journey I get lost in
my mistakes.
What looks to me like weakness is a
canvas for restraint.
My story isn't over. My story's just
begun.
If you want to find me, cuz that's what
my father does.
Feel you want to find me cuz that's what
my father does. Ooh,
lay your burdens down. Ooh,
[Music]
you're in the father's house. Check your
shame at the door
anymore.
You're in the father's house. Yeah.
[Music]
Arriv's not the end game. The journey's
where you are.
You never wanted.
You just wanted my heart. And the story
isn't over. The story isn't good.
Failures never found
the father.
Failures never find when the father's in
your burdens.
in the father's house. Check your shame
at the door.
[Music]
You're in the father's house.
ing prodigals.
Prodigals come on
the earth is final.
Love is on the move. When the father's
in the room
is rewind
[Music]
miracles take place
find
love is breaking through and the
father's in the room.
Tear the walls away.
Struggles now shaking.
Love is breaking through and the
father's in the room.
Love is breaking through and
let your bird down.
Shake your sh.
Yeah.
You're in
your father.
You're in the father's house.
[Music]
All right, kiddos. You are free to go to
where you go. Wasn't that great
instructions? Mindy would be so proud of
me. Thank you. Huge thank you to all the
kids ministry people. They they pour so
much love and energy into our kiddos.
At this time, we're going to head into
prayers of the people. And if you're not
familiar, this is a a longheld tradition
in the church, but something we've done
for for a long time as well. Um, we're
going to read this together. Uh, I'll
read the leader part and then you can
read the part that says, "All
for this city of Saxi, Texas, and for
every city and community and all who
live in them. We pray to you for the
good earth you have given us and the
wisdom and will to conserve it. We pray
to you for the old and the sick. For the
widow and orphan, for the injured and
suffering, we pray to you. For the poor
and the oppressed, the unemployed and
destitute, for prisoners and captives,
and all who remember and care for them.
We pray to you for the vulnerable, the
marginalized, and those unjustly
targeted for their gender, sexuality,
race, or other perceived difference. We
pray to you for those experiencing loss,
loneliness, and disconnection. And for
those struggling with mental and
emotional health, we pray to you.
Lord, we know that you love us and that
you hear us. So we lift these names and
situations up to you.
[Music]
For the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts. We pray to you that they may
have life and light, healing and hope,
peace, and a deep sense of your
presence. Amen.
[Music]
There's a grace when my heart is under
fire.
[Music]
another way when the walls are closing
in.
And when I look at the space between
where I used to be, there is
I know I will never be alone.
There was another in the fire
standing next to me. There was another
in the waters
holding back your seas.
Should I ever need remind me of how I've
been set free
is a cross that bears the burden.
Another died for me. There is another in
the fire.
[Music]
All my death ever live beneath the
waters.
[Music]
I'm no longer a slave to my sin anymore.
Should I fall in the space between
me and me,
either way, I will bow to the things of
this world. And I know
I know I will never be alone.
There is another in the fire
standing next to me.
There is another in the waters
holding back the sea.
Should I ever need reminding
power set me free. There is a grave who
holds nobody.
Power lives in me. There is another in
the fire.
Oh,
there is another in the fire.
I can see the light in the darkness. As
the darkness,
I can feel the roar in the heaven.
There's a space between.
I can feel the ground shake between us.
There's a prison walls ging. Nothing
stands between us.
Nothing stands between us.
[Music]
And nothing stands.
There is no other name but the name that
is Jesus.
[Music]
He who was and still is and will be
through it all.
So come with me in the space between all
the things unseen and this revenue.
I know I will never be alone.
[Music]
There'll be another in the fire
standing next to me.
be another in the waters
holding back the seas
should I ever need my
good you to me
come the joy from every battle cuz I
know that's where you'll be I can see it
I can see the light in the darkness as
darkness
to him. I can hear the roar in the
heaven. There's a space between
I can feel the ground shake us as a
prison wall be
another in the fire
standing next to me.
be another in the waters
holding back the seas.
Should I ever need reminding
you to me? Count the joy of every battle
cuz I know that's where you'll be. I
count the joy come every battle cuz I
know that's where you'll be. I count the
joy come every battle cuz I know that's
where you'll be.
[Music]
Let the king of my heart be the mountain
where I run, the fountain I drink from.
Oh, he is my soul.
Let the king of my heart be the shadow
where I hide, the ransom for my life.
Oh, he is my singing it out. You are
good. You are good.
Good.
Oh,
you are good.
Good.
Oh,
you are good.
Good.
You are good.
Oh,
let the king of my heart be the wind
inside my sails, the anchor in the
wings. Oh, is my song.
You're the king of my heart. Be the fire
inside my veins. The echo of my days.
Oh, he is my song.
Let the king of my heart be the fire
inside my veins.
The echo of my days. Oh, he is my song.
You are good.
Good.
Oh,
you are good.
You are good.
[Music]
Oh,
you're never going to let never going to
let me down.
You're never going to let never going to
let me down. down.
let me down.
You're never going to let never I know
you never
You're never going to never going to let
me down.
You're never going to let never going to
let me down.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Hey,
you are good.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. Heat.
Never let never let me down cuz you are
good.
Oh,
you are good.
No,
Oh,
you are good.
[Music]
Yes, Lord. We we hang hang on every word
of yours that is good.
Every characteristic of who you are is
good.
Every good and perfect gift is good.
Everything about you.
[Music]
Lord, when we feel that we are swirling
in a whirlpool of bad,
we trust in your goodness.
Even though it may not make sense to us
all the time or even a little bit of the
time, we trust in your goodness.
So Lord, comfort our hearts,
open our eyes and our ears.
Help
us to be receivers of your good,
multipliers of your good.
We ask this in your holy name. Amen.
[Music]
If you have a minute, go ahead and pass
the peace of Christ to each other and
we'll get started.
Well, welcome. I love July at the table
for many reasons. One, it's when my
husband and I first started checking out
the table, and it's fond memories.
Obviously, we stuck around. It was
awesome. Two, I really like the fact
that the table models the things the
values of which that they say they do,
right? Like we say, oh, we value rest.
Well, we actually put that into
practice. So, the month of July, we give
our pastor Brett, our worship leader,
Maggie, and our children's and youth uh
person, um, nope, Mindy, our worship,
and Maggie out there. Um, we give them
the month off. We say rest. Rest. We
value you. We appreciate all of the hard
work that you do, but rest. Um, and we
hope that you too are getting some time
whether it be this month of July or
elsewhere to get your rest. And so the
third reason is that I love July is
because it gives us the opportunity to
see the abundant riches of everything
that makes up the table. Whether it be
from the awesomeness of Jesse and the
band who come and lead us in worship or
guest speakers like today we have Anna
who's gonna come and share with us. Um
Anna has been with the table for three
years uh by train. She's an eighth grade
teacher. Um and I think my favorite Anna
was one of my favorites first when I was
observing at the table because man there
if there was a kid who was getting a
little squirly, she'd you could turn his
voice. It wasn't like me, but it was
like serious business. teacher Anna had
arrived and licking those kids that
engaged. So, um I hope you all enjoy as
much as I am excited to hear from
Potter.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you.
Well, hello. I am so excited to be here
tonight. Um and just to talk with you
all. Um again, thank you so much for the
introduction. Um I am Anna Potter. A
little bit about me. I was raised in the
Church of Christ. So, my foundation
um looks a little bit different than
others foundations. Um but I'm really
thankful for the foundation that my
church home gave me. Um and it allowed
me to
create a relationship with God that was
fully my own even from a young age. Um I
had parents that instilled that in me.
And so tonight, I just kind of want to
share my relationship with God and some
of the things he's taught me throughout
my life. Um, when Brett first approached
me, I was not very confident about this.
I actually was kind of like, Brett, I
think you're reaching out to the wrong
person. I think you meant to text
someone else. It's no big deal. Um, you
can just text them. It's fine. Um, but
then I was talking with my amazing wife,
Devon, and she was like, "Anna, you've
been in the church your whole life. your
mom's a minister. I think I think Brett
put picked you for a reason. Um so I am
going to try to do Brett some justice
and if y'all will I um I just want to
kind of share with you all my journey.
So as I started thinking about what
experiences God has allowed me to go
through, I landed on my favorite book of
the Bible and that is Job. While that is
an or unorthodox favorite,
uh it has been near and dear to my heart
my whole life. Um I feel like Job is
someone that almost anyone can relate
to. Uh my throughout my entire life, I
have felt a strong personal connection
to him with the life experiences that
I've gone through that my family has
gone through
especially in my early adulthood life.
Um your early 20s are not a joke. Uh, I
don't know why people made it look
exciting because that has not been my
experience. I'm really looking forward
to like my 40s. That's when I think life
will be good. Um, for those of you that
haven't hit your early 20s yet, I'm
sorry. Maybe you'll have a different
outcome. And I wish that for you. I
really wish a great early 20s.
So, if you don't mind, I want to share
with y'all Job and some of the life
lessons that God has used through the
book of Job and my own life. Our focus
is going to be life be life in lessons
from Job. And that phrase actually came
from a student of mine when in the
beginning of class we do this thing
called good things. And it is a time
where my kids get to share something
good going on in their life. Um it is
just to set a positive environment in
our classroom. Um and to let them know
like hey bad things are going on but
let's focus on some of the good. And one
of my kiddos, I love him more than
anything. I got to end my day with him.
He said, "Well, Miss Jordan,
it's not been a very good day, but life
be." And he just went on about his day.
And I was like, "How amazing of a of a
perspective is that from a 13-year-old
boy that you know what, sometimes life
is just life and it's rough and it's
hard and that's okay."
So, the book of Job opens with a
striking paradox. You have a man of
great faith who suffers greatly.
In the first two chapters, we are
introduced to Job. We learn that he is a
good man. He's upright, God-fearing.
He's got seven d uh seven sons, three
daughters, and plenty of thousands of
animals in a flourishing home. People
look up to Job. They say he's a good
man.
But then behind a curtain in the unseen
realm, a conversation takes place in
heaven that changes everything in a
matter of a second. We are directed to a
conversation between God and Satan. I'm
going to give you a quick rundown of
this. This is not from the Bible. This
is just my take on it. Okay. So, God
sees Satan and he's like, "What have you
been up to?" And Satan's like, "Oh, you
know, the usual roaming the earth,
wreaking havoc, and trying to pull
people from you." which already, right,
we're in the very beginning of this and
I'm like, Satan, you're starting off
really strong. Let's all remember he did
kick you out. Like, let's remember that.
So, let's maybe think about how we
approach God, right? Um, but he doesn't,
you know, so God's response is great. He
says, "Well, have you met my servant
Job?" He hasn't turned away from me. In
fact, in a world of sin, he's still an
upright man. People turn to Job. He has
not cursed my name.
Satan's very sassy and he's like, "Well,
obviously Job hasn't forsaken you. He's
had a perfectly good life. Why would he
need to curse you?"
So God is like, "Bet, Satan, I'm going
to let you have Adam,
but you can't kill Job. That's the one
rule. You can't kill him." And Satan's
like, "Bet."
So,
I want to add because that I feel like
we can take this and maybe be like,
"God, what are you doing? Why are you
offering up someone that you just said
has been a follower of you?"
But God allows Satan to test Job not
because our God is a cruel God, but
because he knows that Job's faith is
real.
So, we're going to look really quickly
at Job 1 13-18.
This is Satan's first attempt to knock
Job down. One day when Job's sons and
daughters were feasting and drinking
wine at the oldest brother's house, a
messenger came to Job and said, "The
oxen were plowing and the donkeys were
grazing nearby, and the Sabians attacked
and made off with them." They put the
servants to the sword, and I am the only
one who has escaped to tell you. While
he is still speaking, another messenger
comes in and he says, "The fire of God
fell from the heavens and burned up the
sheep and the servants and I am the only
one who has escaped to tell you." And
while he is still speaking, yet another
messenger comes in and he says, "The
Calaldanss formed three raiding parties
and swept down on your camels and made
off with them. They put the servants to
the sword and I am the only one who has
escaped to tell you." And here we go.
While another one was or while he was
still speaking, another messenger comes
and says, "Your sons and daughters were
feasting and drinking wine at the oldest
brother's house when suddenly a mighty
wind swept in from the desert and struck
the four corners of the house. It
collapsed on them, and they are dead.
And I am the only one who has escaped to
tell you."
In these verses, we start to see how
quickly Job's life begins to
deteriorate.
He loses his livestock, his servants,
and his very own children, leaving a
single servant from each tragedy to
share what has happened.
And in the midst of this unimaginable
suffering, Job does something that I
think many times we forget to do. He
worships.
He grieavves. Yes, he tears his robe and
he shaves his head, but he also falls to
the ground and says, "The Lord gave and
the Lord has taken away. Blessed be the
name of our Lord."
And that is where our journey begins.
Not with easy answers, but with chaos.
Not with a life spared from pain, but
with a faith that refuses to let go even
in the fire.
So that was just day one. The next day,
Satan comes back and he goes after Job
again. And this time, he covers Job's
entire body in blistering soores.
These sores are so unbearable that Job
finds a broken piece of pottery and he
starts to physically scrape his body to
get these blisters off of him.
And about this time, we start to see his
wife.
And his wife comes in and she sees him
in this gruesome agony with these
blisters all over. They've just lost
their children. She's in mourning.
They've lost everything that could ever
mean something to them. And she sees Job
and she sees how miserable she is. And
she says, "Job, have you not had enough
already? Curse God and just die. Just
the only thing better than this is death
at this point. So curse God and be done.
And I wonder how many times in our own
lives when we're just fed up. We feel
like we've been knocked down. We get
back up. Here comes another wave
crashing us down and we just can't seem
to get our heads above water. And how
many times are we the wife where we just
want to say, "God, I'm done. I'm not
doing this anymore. I'm just going to
curse you and we're going to be done.
We're going to walk away."
Job's response is so good, though.
He says, "You are talking like a foolish
woman."
Which in Hebrew, which in Hebrew, this
actually translates to being morally
deficient. So, it's not like you're just
a fool. No, no, you are corrupt.
How dare you? And again, remember like
he's speaking to his wife, y'all. You
are morally deficient. How dare you come
to me? Shall we not accept or sorry,
shall we accept good from God and not
trouble?
Here's the thing. Job is literally
living in his own hell. And still, he
says, are we to expect a perfect life
from God?
As we walk through Job's story, we're
going to learn what it means to welcome
in the bad, not because we enjoy it, but
because God is meeting us in those pain,
those moments. Because he's still
speaking. He's still working and because
in the end God has the final word.
So back to the story and I'm not going
to read it directly from the Bible
because this goes on for many chapters.
And this is when Job's friends come to
see him.
And honestly there their conversations I
think could be a whole series. So we're
just going to kind of get a quick
version of it.
So at first they're coming down the road
and they see Job and they see the state
that he is in.
And they immediately tear their robes
and pour sand on them on their heads
before even talking with their friend.
They are getting they are preparing
themselves to meet him in his own depths
to meet him where he is.
For seven days and seven nights they sit
in silence.
They just sit. They just are. They don't
try to make him feel better. They don't
try to
come up with anecdotes or distract him.
No, they just sit with him. They feel
what their friend is feeling and they
hold it with him.
Finally,
Job breaks the silence and he actually
curses the day he was born.
But notice that he still hasn't cursed
God. His whole life has been ripped away
from him in a matter of a day. and his
body is now facing unforeseen health
problems,
but instead he still just curses the day
that he was born.
Then his friends start to speak. And if
you've ever read the story of Job, um
his friends aren't helpful. So one of
his friends literally chimes in and is
like, "Well, what have you done? You
clearly done something to upset God."
I don't know about you, but if like my
kids have just died, I've lost
everything. And then you look at me and
you're like, "So, what have you done?"
I'm going to be like, "Get out. Please
leave. Stage left." Um, another friend,
another friend, um, kind of insinuates
or alludes to the fact that his children
kind of got what was coming to them
because they were kind of being sinful.
Um, and that that was a way of answering
to their sin. And then another one, he's
a little bit helpful. He encourages him
to continue to hold steadfast to God um
and to seek the advice of their elders,
to rely on their wisdom.
Again, he's just lost everything. And
these friends are trying to play the
blame game.
And this goes on
for a very long time. I mean, many
chapters.
And finally, Job speaks because I mean,
you can only hear that so much before
you get fed up. And Job does. And he
says, "Y'all are horrible comforters.
Like, y'all are actually terrible at
this. Just let me be because if I were
in your shoes, it would be really easy
to say the things you are saying, but
I'm not. I'm in living my own hell. I've
just lost everything. I don't need this
right now. I don't need to hear you."
And while they were all conversing, Job
was also crying out aloud to God.
He was praising him, but he was also
asking a lot of questions.
Asking God, what has he done? Asking God
to see him where he is. He's crying out
for answers. And he's met with no
response.
This dialogue, by the way, takes up 35
chapters.
35 chapters. living and sleeping in his
own depths of pain and anguish.
35 chapters of friends blaming him,
doubting him, offering useless advice
that comes from someone not in their own
depths, and even encouragement to
forsake God.
35 chapters of Job crying out to the
Lord only to be met with silence, with
no answers.
Yet he continues to praise God and stay
in communication with him.
He lost everything,
but he still managed to praise God and
keep a line of communication open.
This is something that I never thought I
would relate to.
But then my early 20s hit and I learned
that depths are kind of just part of
life, right? going through bad isn't
ever gonna not exist. So, you just kind
of have to learn to go through it. So,
if it's okay with y'all, I want to step
away for a second from the story of Job
and I kind of want to share a season of
my own deaths.
I'm lucky to say that I know what God
has called me to do with my life and
that's to educate children and to share
God with those children.
And this was something that for a very
long time I tried to run away from.
Okay, my mom is a children's minister.
My sister does children's ministry. Um,
and so my entire life I was told that
that was going to be my future. Anna,
you're so good at it. Your mom is so
good at it. Of course you're going to
love children. Of course you're going to
do something with children. And if you
know me pretty well, you know, I really
don't like being told what I'm going to
be doing.
So, I avoided it. Um, but as we've seen
through the Bible and through the story
of Jonah and many others, if God has a
plan for you and God has said you're
going to do something, it's going to
happen. So,
I remember when I finally decided to
give up and follow what God wanted for
me. And I called my mom who is my best
friend. She's my rock. She's my guide.
She is the pillar on which I guide my
life.
And I told her I was going to change my
major to education
and there was a very long pause on the
phone. And one thing about my mom, she's
a very humble woman. I She is the
epitome of humility and kindness and
goodness.
Not when it comes to her kids though. So
I remember there was a pause and then I
can hear her smiling through the phone.
She goes, "Hm,
I think I remember someone telling you
that in high school." Now, that someone
was my mom. Okay. Uh my mom was the one
that told me I needed to do that. And I
remember just for a moment how proud she
sounded, but I also remember
just my own humility in that moment that
I fought something for so long that God
was calling me to.
So I decided to go to&m commerce for
education
and I got into my first job. It was in
an afterchool program for a lot of
atrisisk youths
and I loved that job. Oh man, did I love
that job. I loved it so much that I made
my entire world centered in commerce.
Devon moved there for me. We bought our
we got our first apartment there. We got
engaged there. Devon got into the school
district there. Um,
we even got married there and it was
home. They helped grow me into the adult
that I am. They kind of took baby adult
Anna and baby adult Devon and they loved
on us and they grew us into adults.
The kids became my heart and my soul.
There was not a single thing I wouldn't
do for them. Their parents knew they
could call me at any time and I would
answer that phone. And for the first
time in my life, I finally felt I was
where I would belonged.
It was my first moment
of not feeling like the outsider
and being loved for my true self. And it
was amazing.
Now, here's the thing. Things can change
really quickly. And the culture at this
job started to shift. I was in my third
year
and it was becoming really hard. I was
miserable. I was exhausted. I was burned
out and
it was hard. But I had the kids and that
was enough to keep me going. That was
enough to keep me there.
We were facing leadership changes. We
were facing a lot of people fighting
against my kids. Um, and I had to learn
a really hard lesson that speaking up
comes with many consequences.
On October 31st, I was called into a
meeting with my boss.
And sometimes your body just has a way
of knowing that something bad's not
bad's about to happen. And it did.
I walked out of that job or out of that
meeting without a job and without a
single chance to say goodbye to my kids.
Oh, and I had just gotten married the
weekend before. So, now I get to uh make
a phone call to my wife saying, by the
way, she worked at the same school as
me, saying, "Hey, I'm not returning to
the school. Um, and I won't be returning
ever to that school. I don't have a job
there. And also, I know we just got
married and we just moved into a house.
We're down to one income."
After I called her, I called my mom.
Then I remember calling her and just
sobbing the second the dial tone ended
and she picked up.
No words could come out. There was
nothing I could say. She knew. She knew
by my brokenness and the the
sobs that I didn't have that job anymore
and I was broken.
And I remember she didn't say anything.
She didn't try to comfort me. She didn't
try to make it seem better.
She just sat with me
and it seemed like forever. I I think I
sat on that phone with her in silence
for 15 minutes
and she just sat with me in my sorrow
and my pain and I remember she said, "I
love you and I'm sorry."
I said, "I love you, too." She hung up
and then I was left alone to sit with my
thoughts and I couldn't understand
how this was all happening. I was great
at my job. I loved the kids. I built a
relationship with them and their
families. I was I I was at their famil
family's funerals. I was at their
birthdays. Anything that they needed me
to be there for, I was there.
I felt empty and I felt angry.
God, this is what you've called me to.
So why in the blink of an eye are you
ripping it all away from me? This place
where I have built a home, why are you
taking this from me?
And this is the first life lesson that I
learned.
Life keeps going. Even when you are in
your depth, life is still happening. It
doesn't stop because your heart you're
hurt. doesn't stop because of the hard
things going on in your life.
So, I gave myself two days.
Two days to feel everything. To be
angry, to be sad, to sit in my pity,
but I needed a job. So, I applied for a
couple of different districts and I was
offered a couple of different positions.
I ended up going with one closer to
home. I was still angry. I was still
confused, heartbroken, and honestly not
loving this new place that I took a job
at. And I kept crying.
And I remember I cried out to God. And I
remember I just said to him at one
point, "God, just leave me where you
want me cuz I don't care at this point.
You're a good God."
And honestly, that was really hard to
say
because I learned
that God is always good. You just might
not be having the goodness in that
moment.
His goodness is elsewhere. And in this
moment, he wants you to be in that mad.
He wants to sit with you in that.
So, I remember starting at this new
district and this was not a district I
was used to. I had never worked in a 1A
before. I didn't know they existed. I
didn't know that you could have pre-K
through 12th all in one building. I came
from a 6A district so this was uh eye
opening. Okay. like this is a district.
I mean so small that they missed school
for hunting
and it was excused.
Okay, it was small. So, as you can
imagine, I stuck out pretty well. And at
this point, I was kind of just going
through the motions. But then God showed
me that I could love kids anywhere. So,
I returned that next school year. We
were approaching
um fall break and a lot of sports were
kind of kicking up and I remember all
these kids started inviting me to their
stuff and up until then I hadn't been
really involved. I still had a lot of
hurt. I felt like I was betraying my
first set of kids in a way. But I
remember fall break was approaching and
they're like, "Miss Jordan, please come
watch us play this. Come with us to do
this." And I started to open myself back
up. I went to all their basketball
games. I went to their playoff games. If
they had anything that they wanted me
at, I was there.
And then Christmas break is a fast
approaching.
And I'm walking into the school to start
my day like I normally would, and I'm
being called into the principal's
office.
My stomach drops because I've been here
before. And this time, I know what's
coming.
So now it's time that I make that same
phone call.
This time I call Devon first and then I
call my mom.
And I sobb because I don't understand
what is happening. I'm pouring into kids
and giving what I have left. And at this
point, I have nothing left.
I'm broken. And I don't know how things
could get any worse or what I'm going to
do. What I do know is right, I'm right
back where I was a year ago.
The exact same place.
Except this time, God showed me that it
can get worse.
I remember I was looking for jobs and I
get a phone call from my from my dad and
he tells me
that my best friend, my rock, she's
really sick and it's not looking so good
for her. My mom was going to the
hospital. Luckily, I didn't have a job,
so I was able to drop everything and go.
I remember walking into that room and I
really believe that parents just
shouldn't get sick
because I have never felt more helpless
or small walking into a room
there. My mother was this woman that
I've looked to for strength and guidance
my entire life.
She's now laying in a bed looking small
and frail.
This woman that has instilled in me the
faith that I have,
the most God-fearing and upright person
I know,
and all I can see is this massive fight
she has ahead of her.
And then I turn and I see my dad
and I see him watching the love of his
life, his best friend, going through the
unimaginable.
And for a second I thought about my own
pain and then I thought about what he
must be feeling.
They've been together since they were
15.
They are still married to this day.
So I leave that hospital
and I call De and I let her know that
I'm on my way back home.
And then I remember driving that whole
way with no music. Just not normal for
me. It's just me and my thoughts and
God. I was living in my own hell. And I
remember crying out to God, which I
think at this point it was more like
screaming.
Why was all of this happening?
What did I do to be here in this moment?
And then I got really angry because what
did my mom do to be here in this moment?
What was he doing? Because most of the
time I could see what he was doing in my
life. And this time I don't get it. I
don't see what he's doing.
And all I met with is silence.
My dad calls me. My biggest fear was
coming true.
My mom had cancer.
But they couldn't even treat the cancer
because her body was already in sepsis.
And I remember I was pleading with God
because moms just don't deserve to be
sick. They're too good.
And still nothing, just silence.
And over the next few weeks, I was
looking for a job and navigating
everything with my mom.
And there were no words to describe the
hell I was going through. I didn't speak
to many people. I remember arguing with
God a lot. And then somewhere along the
way, my prayers changed.
I took a page out of Job's book.
And instead of only focusing on my pain
and my heartbreak, I began to praise
God.
Praise him for being a good father. Even
though I honestly didn't feel the good.
And he taught me that he is in control
and he was feeling my pain.
that even though it was my worst fear
and that losing my mom scared me more
than anything that that was what
happened, God still had a hand in it and
God was going to use that in some way
because he was in control and he had
final say.
Shortly after that, a friend of mine
texts me and she tells me that she has a
job for me. But you're not going to be
teaching reading, you're going to teach
science.
Um, yikes. And it's going to be an
uphill struggle in that classroom.
Well, I take the job cuz I need a job.
And I started to get my bearings again.
And things with my mom are starting to
become clearer. We're getting more
answers than we are met with questions.
And just like with Job, God finally
spoke.
So, we're going to look back now at the
book of Job, specifically chapter 38.
God finally speaks to Job
and he questions Job. He questions Job
to get him to think about the mightiness
of who his God is to remind him. And he
says things like, "Were you there when I
created the whole world?" Oh, I'm sorry.
Can you divide the night sky and the day
sky? Did you create man? Oh, no, you
didn't. So, maybe have some faith in me,
okay?
Job is restored and God provides 10
times what he had before.
You see, like Job, I was never in my
depths alone. God God was always there
hurting with me, crying with me, and
even breaking with me. So these are the
few things that God has taught me that
Job has also taught me.
Welcome the bad. Because God never
promised easy. Job was a righteous man,
blameless, upright, God-fearing, and yet
he lost everything. His children, his
health, and even his wealth.
In fact, we were never promised a life
without suffering. If you look at John
16:33, we're actually promised trials.
But when we welcome the uh the bad like
Job does, we begin to see that God is
still present, that he is still working.
Job didn't pretend that bad wasn't
painful. He tore his robe. He shaved his
head. He sat in silence.
But in the same breath, he worshiped
God.
The second one, welcome the bad even
when it is ugly.
Job's suffering got ugly. His friends
accused him. His wife told him to curse
God. He sat in ashes. He questioned God.
He was in the depths of despair, barely
holding on. But God welcomed it. God did
not condemn Job for his raw honesty.
God doesn't silence Job. Instead, he
lets him get it out and then he answers.
Bring your brokenness and questions to
God. Like Job, speak from the depths
because God can handle your hardest
cries.
The third thought is welcome the bad
because God is at work in it.
Now, here's the thing. Be ready because
after you've screamed and you've cried
or you've even cursed God, God's about
to do something amazing.
Looking back at the story of Job, Job
couldn't see that heavenly conversation
happening in chapters 1 and two. He
didn't know that his suffering was not
meaningless. What he did know was who
his God was. And he was ready for
whatever that meant.
Job was aware of his suffering. He was
aware of the doubt surrounding him. And
he had no idea when it would end.
But Job welcomed it because he knew who
was in control. At the end, God restored
Job, but not before revealing his power,
majesty, and sovereignty.
And this is what Job responds with. He
says, "I had heard of you by the hearing
of my ear, but now my eyes see you."
The bad led Job to a deeper knowledge of
God than he had ever known before.
Sometimes the most beautiful lessons,
moments, or growth occur in the bad. So
don't rush through it. God's growing you
in it. And lastly, welcome the bad
because God has the final word.
God vindicates Job. He restores him. He
rebukes the friends. When we are at our
weakest, he is at his strongest. That's
exactly what we see in Job. The man who
was brought low is lifted up. Not
because he fought his way back, but
because God never left him. So, we don't
know each other. We don't know our
stories or our pain, but God does. If
you're going through a season of
darkness or pain, God is with you. And I
pray that in his time, he speaks to you.
Thank you, Anna, for so vulnerably
reminding us of God's presence and
goodness. At this time, we are going to
take communion. Um, a couple reminders.
We practice an open table. So, anybody
who wants to participate can
participate. What we do is that we go
rowby row and come down the middle and
we'll have the the wine and the bread up
here. Um, the bread is gluten-free.
There's both wine and grape juice. The
wine is the red. The grape juice is um a
clearish color. Um,
and so this is the table, not of the
church, but of the Lord. It is made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more. So
come, you who have much faith and you
who have little, you have been here
often and you have not You've been here
a while. You who have tried to follow
and you who have failed, come because it
is the Lord who invites you. It is his
will that those who want him should meet
him here. Come to the table.
[Music]
Thank you, Anna. It was really, really,
really good.
What's really cool is Anna and I did not
talk at all when it came to song
selection. So, that's kind of cool. Um,
if if you want to stand here at the end,
we're going to sing a song called
Crowded Table. And I think it's a really
excellent reminder of that even as we go
through hardship, as we go through
darkness, that the church, this family
can be a huge, huge support. and that
when we have those hard times, it's very
easy to want to pull away from this
family. And this is a a song to be
reminded that to stay with each other.
[Music]
Hold my hand
when you need to let go.
I can be your mountain
when you're in the valley.
I can be your street light
showing you the way home.
If you hold crying
and you need to get home,
I want a house with a rounded
table and a place by the fire for
everyone.
Let us see all the world. But we all
able and bring us back together when the
day
is.
If we want to garden,
we're going to have to sew the seeds,
plant a little happiness,
[Music]
let the roots run deep.
If it's love that we give, then it's
love that we reap. If we want a garden,
we're going to have to sew the seeds.
Yeah. I want a house with a rounded
table and a place
by the fire for everyone.
Let us sing on the world while we're
young and able and bring us back
together when the day is done.
The door is always open. Your pictures
on my wall. And everyone's a little
broken.
And everyone belongs.
Everyone
belongs.
Want a house with a grounded
table and a place by the fire for
everyone.
Let us take on the world while we're
young and able and bring us back
together when the day is done.
And bring us back together when the day
is done.
All
[Music]
Thank you so much for joining us this
evening.
If you are new, we would like love for
you to fill out a card on the table or
you can scan the QR code. Uh just uh
fill out a visitor's card. Uh we can
answer any questions that you may have
and that you can uh any that you uh have
about us. Would love for you to do that
on your way out.
[Music]
Generosity is a key aspect of the life
and adoration of worship. To give
financially, you can scan the QR code or
visit the table at the tablet tx.org.
[Music]
If you call the table home but don't
currently serve on a ministry team and
you would like to try anything uh of of
them out, we have a tech team, kids
ministry host team. They're currently
the most uh in the need. Uh fill out a
card on the table or you can also scan
the QR code for that.
Don't forget Hack Creek tonight after
for the services and I believe Jared and
your host there. That's Jared in the
back.
Um, so we hope everyone so you can ask
if because I'm not sure of the address.
So you can ask afterwards.
So we hope to see you.
All right. Let me send you um into your
week with this blessing.
You can hold out your hands and hand in
a posture to receive or just open your
hearts.
[Music]
You are a child of God.
You
are a child of God.
This is true on your best day. And this
is true
on your worst day.
So as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between,
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved,
you are worthy,
and you are accepted just as you are.
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with. Be blessed.
Have a good week and we hope to see you
back next here next Sunday after hat
freak evening.
Good night.
[Music]
The door is always open. your pictures
on my wall.
Everyone's a little broken.
Everyone belongs.
Yeah, everyone belongs.
I want a house with a rounded
table and a place by the fire for
everyone.
Let us change on the world while we're
young and able and bring us back
together when the day is done.
And bring us back together when the day
is done.
[Music]
Oops.
Yay.
Same. Me, too.